You can now build entire movies shot by
shot using my new free workflow. Just
give it reference images of your
characters and location, and the
workflow automatically creates a virtual
environment where you can direct your
scenes with simple text prompts. The
workflow will keep the likeness of your
characters without the need of training
an additional model like a Laura. And
any style works, [music] realistic,
anime, clamation, you name it. You can
also use pose references or your own
storyboard scribbles for more precise
control.
>> [music]
>> All of this is based on open source
models, so you can run everything on
your own computer for free. So, let's
start building a movie.
I've drawn dozens of storyboards for my
film projects in the past. And I love
this approach to film making because you
don't just get an idea of your final
movie. You start living and exploring
this world. But AI models can take this
concept even further, allowing you to
generate the final shots with lighting,
framing, and the final characters. This
is made possible by the Gwen image edit
model. It's one of these new
instruction-based image models that
understand concepts in images. So, I can
just say, "Here's a background. Here's
my character. Put this character into
this background and it's done." Since
its release, people have been improving
this model by training these small extra
models for it called Loras. Some of them
just improve character consistency, some
improve realism. But my favorite one is
the next scene Laura by Lovis 93. This
one allows you to take an image and then
just tell the model what the next scene
will look like. Built on this
foundation, I created a workflow for
CompuI, a free node-based interface for
AI models that allows you to plan out
entire scenes shot by shot. To use it,
first you need to install CompuI, and we
have a free guide for that on our
website. Once it's installed, just
download the workflow JSON file and drag
and drop it into the Confui interface.
Now, you might need to install a few
missing custom nodes. To do this, simply
go to the Comfi Manager. Click install
missing custom nodes. Select all of them
and click install. When it's done,
restart Confui and all the nodes should
be here. Now, you need to download the
actual AI models. And you can find all
of them in these yellow nodes to the
left of this workflow right here next to
the model loader nodes. And you can see
here I'm using a GGUF version of this
model. GGF is basically a way to
compress model size so it can run on
older GPUs that don't have a lot of
VRAM. If you follow this link in the
workflow, you can see all the different
GGF versions. And you should select a
version that comfortably fits on your
GPU's VRAM. I have 24 GB, so I could
easily run the Q8 version right here.
But to show you more realistic results,
for all examples that I've shown, I used
this Q5 version right here that easily
would fit on a 16 GB VRAM card. So once
you've downloaded the model that you
want to use, you just need to go into
your confui folder. Comi
models unit and I've created my own GGF
folder right here and put everything
inside here. Make sure to click R in
comi to refresh the window and select
the version that you want to use right
here. Repeat this process for all the
other loras and models that I've added
here. When you're done with this, you
can start using the workflow. We are
working from left to right. So, let's
zoom in on the top left right here. Here
you can set your final image dimensions.
And I'm just using HD resolution, which
works really great. Next, you can change
the steps and the CFG, but you shouldn't
change them because we're using this
Lura right here, the image lightning
four step Laura, which will just speed
up Gwen image edit so it can run on only
four steps. And then the CFG needs to be
at one. And then we can create our scene
name. This will then create a folder
where all the images that we create here
will be saved out to. I will call mine
restaurant and maybe a version number
because today I want to create one of
these scenes that you see constantly in
film making but that are actually very
hard to do with AI. Two characters
interacting and talking to each other in
one consistent location. And for this we
first need to load in our characters.
And I just drag and drop them in. So we
have this stylish model kind of woman
here. And we have this man here with an
interesting pattern on his suit or like
his shirt. Here you can upload a third
reference. For example, a third
character. Uh I just loaded in my
environment. Though this is not usually
the place to do it. You would do this
here. I have this environment group
right here. So just drag and drop in
your location here. When you imported
your references like this, you can go to
the first image generation group. And
now we need to create a prompt for what
we want to see. In this case, I created
a prompt. The characters are at a table
in a restaurant. They are sitting
opposite of each other, a cinematic
movie scene with professional lighting.
You see, it's a really simple prompt.
And now we have to select the up to
three references that we want to use.
Here in these get image nodes, you can
select the images that you want to use.
The first image is image one. So I
selected image one. We have image number
two. That's him. So I loaded this here.
And finally down here we have the
environment. So I also loaded in the
environment. If you want you can also
put like names in here. Maybe she's
called Tina. I don't know. And then you
can also see it changed in this get
image note right here. It's good to keep
things more organized like this so you
don't lose track of what you're doing.
But this is really all there is to it.
So I just click run and it's done. And
you can see our two characters are
sitting at the exact table that we
wanted them to. Now let's start actually
building the next scenes. So, I just
activate this next group right here.
This one uses the next scene, Laura. So,
we can create a prompt like this. Next
scene. The camera is behind the man,
creating an over-the-shoulder shot,
showing a frontal view of the woman
smiling. And now, what I'm doing is I'm
taking the output image. You can see
down here, you can name the output for
each group. This is out one. So, I'm
loading in out one right here. And then
I'm also using this reference right
here. And you can see this failed
completely. We didn't rotate the camera.
There's now an additional man. So we
need to be a bit more specific in the
prompt. What really helps is to describe
the image in more detail. And instead of
prompting how the camera move, it really
helps to describe where things are in
space. Now half the photos obstructed by
the man's back. The large window is to
the right. Behind the woman to the left
is a bar. And now we have a composition
that's closer to what I originally
wanted. What you can do now is just
select this whole group and just copy it
to create your next scene. Maybe we want
to zoom in on this character's face. So
all I need to do is switch this input
here to out two. And we can rename this
group right here to out three. Face
fills the entire image just to make sure
that we really want to be really close
to her. And because now her look changed
a little bit. So I'm connecting the
original image, image number one here,
I'm connecting that again to the prompt
just to remind it what the woman really
looks like. And now you can see it's a
lot closer and the earrings are angular
again. Now before we start building out
the whole movie like this, let me show
you the other features of this workflow.
And you can find these down here. The
first one is the option to use a pose
reference. So, let's say, for example,
we like this shot, but we want to make
her drink from the glass of wine here in
a specific pose. I found a reference
image for exactly that. So, I can just
import that right here.
And then I'm going to duplicate this
group. And so, just so we don't lose it,
I will just copy the group, put it here.
And next, let's name this something like
this. Image pose wine. Come up here. We
want to stay pretty close to this image
right here. This is out too. So I will
reference that here. And next I'm going
to select my wine pose reference and
connect that. Now we just need to create
a simple prompt like this. And now she's
drinking from the glass of wine. Pretty
close to the original input pose that we
got from right here. I don't use this
pose reference often because prompting
usually is good enough. But if you have
an exact composition in mind, this is a
good way to reference that. But
sometimes prompting is not enough. for
example, when you want to change the
camera angle and keep the backgrounds
consistent. This can be quite the
challenge with Gwen image edit. So my
idea was to generate a 360° image of the
full environment so the model
understands the full geometry of the
scene. I tried creating such an image
with Gwen image edit but unfortunately
the results were not too good. So what I
did is I created my own data set of 20
real 360° images and then used them to
train my own Gwen image edit. Laura
showing Gwen image edit. These real 360°
images helped to train the model to
understand what a real 360° image should
look like. If you want to train your own
Loras, I will link the exact tutorial
that I followed below. But all you need
to do is just download my Laura and make
sure in the beginning of the workflow
that you load it in right here. And then
you can come down here to this bottom
group. And this is where your full
environment will be created. This will
take your environment input image and
add this gray area around that. This
area will stay exactly the same. And
then around that when image edit will
now generate a 360° environment. To tell
it what should be added in this gray
area, you need to come here to this
prompt. And all you need to change is
this part right here. And then it will
create a really cool result like this.
If you do not like that, you can always
come down and change the seat or adjust
the prompt. The problem with this image
is that it is not seamless. To
automatically fix this, I created this
setup right here. That will just lay out
these images so you can see where the
seam is. Then a white mask will be
added. And using this simple prompt,
remove the visible seam. the seam will
be removed from the image. We can use
this environment in multiple ways to
help Gwen image edit. For example, this
image right here will be added together
with our character references in the
reference sheet group. So, we have our
full environment and we have our two
characters and you can see I already
referenced it here for example for this
over- the-sh shoulder shot. And this way
when we create a prompt like this where
we say the bar should be left and the
window should be right. And this way
Gwen image edit can actually understand
oh he's talking about a window that
should be to the right of the character.
To the left should be a bar. So he must
be talking about this area right here.
And this worked really well. You can see
it put the window to the right and the
exact bar in the background. This
reference sheet also helps to keep the
characters more consistent because
you're constantly reminding when image
edit what they should look like. So let
me quickly create the full scene and
then I'm going to show you how I did it
step by step. Okay, so here's the full
scene. Let me quickly walk you through
it. So in the beginning here, we created
a simple base image. The characters are
on at a table. And for this next scene,
I rotated the camera so it's behind the
man looking at the woman sitting in
front of the bar. And to help it keep
the background even more consistent,
what I did now is I added this group
down here. This will take the 360°
reference image that we created below
and it lets you cut out a part of the
image using this mask right here that
should be in the background. And then I
connected this output right here to this
group. Like you've seen, it worked
before, but we had the issue that there
were chairs um in the background that
were not supposed to be there. And now
it's just a bit better. For the next
scene, I did something similar. I wanted
to create a close-up of the man. But how
should Gwen image edit know what the
background should look like? Well, I
just told it. So again, using this
background reference image group, I was
just able to think about where my
characters are. So the man should be
sitting here. So this should be in the
background, right? So I just cropped out
this area right here. It doesn't have to
be absolutely perfect. And then when you
click run, you can see this part will be
cropped out. I just connected that. And
I also referenced the input image of the
man, image number two. And this is all
what was needed to create this image
right here. For the next scene, I wanted
to create a close-up of the man where he
presents a ring. And down below here,
you can see the prompt. Cut to an
extreme close-up of the man's hand
presenting a ring. And I referenced the
first output image. So this image right
here. And I also referenced output
three, which is the previous image right
here. And sometimes using the simplest
approach is the best one. For example,
for this scene right here, for the kiss
scene, I only referenced the first
output image. And then I created this
simple prompt. And that's all that is
needed to make them kiss. The cool thing
about building a modular story like this
is that you can change out the location,
style, or character. So, for example, I
can just come in here back to the
beginning and change out the woman, for
example, and run this whole workflow
again. And the workflow will
automatically replace the woman with the
older one from the reference image. Or
we could change out the location. So
maybe instead of having this cozy
restaurant, we want to have this space
diner right here. And now these two
characters are sitting in a spaceship.
So when you're done, you find all the
output images that you created in comui
output and the name of the folder that
you gave it in the beginning of the
workflow. So now let's actually make
them move. You can use any video model
that allows you to give a start frame
and then generate the video based on
that. And I tested cling v3 and some
other models. But if you want to do it
locally, I recommend using my one 2.2
imagetovideo workflow. You set this up
in the exact same way as the previous
workflow. Just drag and drop that in.
Click install missing custom nodes. And
then you need to download these models
right here. Once you have everything set
up, you can decide if you want to use a
start frame, an end frame, or both to
generate your video. Here, for example,
I used both. This is my start frame. And
then I wanted these characters to move
across the table to kiss each other. So
I connected this here to the start image
and this to the end image. You can set
your resolution right here. This is the
maximum one. If you don't have the best
GPU, I would lower that. I would also
lower the length. I'm using the maximum
of 81 frames. And then all you need to
do is create a simple prompt like this
where you mostly describe the action and
the camera movement. Everything else
will be extracted from the images. Now,
if I want another variation, I can
always come back here and change the
seat or adjust the prompt. But you don't
always have to use an input image and an
end frame. You can also choose just to
use a start frame or just an end frame.
And that's what I did for this shot
right here. I wanted the hand to open,
but I only had this image of the open
hand. So, I connected this one to the
end image and then just created a prompt
like this. And I think it captured it
perfectly. Now, building a movie like
this takes a bit of practice, but you'll
soon get a hang of what kind of prompt
structures and phrases Gwen Image Edit
likes and understands. To help you out,
you can also get the example scenes I
created for this video if you support us
on Patreon. You'll also get access to
advanced workflows and our amazing
Discord community. But most importantly,
you help us keeping these workflows free
for everyone and not having to rely on
sponsors in every single video. So,
thank you a lot for that. So, here are
the final results for the demo scenes
that I created.
[music]
>> [laughter]
>> I hope you enjoyed this video and found
this workflow [music] useful. If you
create a movie with it, feel free to tag
me in your work or send it to me. I
always love to see what you come up
[music] with. Thanks for watching and
thank you to our lovely Patreon
supporters for making these videos
possible. [music] See you next time.
>> [music]